Donald Trump has seemingly again
implicitly admitted that he's
obstructing justice
there are three call them pillars of the
Trump Russia investigation that's being
conducted by robert muller first is was
there a legal coordination or exchange
of things of value between Trump
associates and Russian associates pillar
number two of the investigation is in an
attempt to stop the investigation into
that possible coordination where crimes
committed those crimes could be
obstruction of justice they could be
witnessed tampering there could be other
possible crimes and pillar number three
of Robert Mueller's investigation is
whether financial crimes come to light
as a result of an investigation of the
first two potentially involving Trump
and Russians let's focus in today on
part two obstruction obstruction itself
has many layers for example was the
firing of James Comey obstruction of
justice since Trump admitted that the
firing was meant to hamper the Russia
investigation he said that to Lester
Holt who interviewed him on NBC News
months ago was the request made of James
Comey by Donald Trump to lay off of
Michael Flynn because after all he's a
good guy let the Flynn thing go was that
an attempt to obstruct justice
has there been witness tampering in
possible communications with Michael
Flynn or Paul Manafort or whoever else
and Donald Trump is now tweeted about
the obstruction of justice concerns
yesterday Donald Trump took to Twitter
and said the Russia witch-hunt is
rapidly losing credibility House
Intelligence Committee found no
collusion coordination or anything else
with Russia so now the probe says okay
what else is there how about obstruction
for a made-up phony crime there is no
obstruction it's called fighting back
and those are the key words is there any
other context in which fighting back
against not charges but an investigation
would be considered just the benign
actions of someone defending themselves
if police stop you and are investigating
possible drunk driving they haven't
charged you at which point of course you
lower it will you lawyer up and you
fight back police stopped you and
they're investigating possible drunk
driving
in what way do you fight back in that
investigation that would be considered
acceptable even if the current
investigation is a partisan witch hunt
by Democrats by the way Muller and Comey
are both Republicans their entire lives
even if the investigation has
credibility problems you can't break the
laws to fight the investigation or how
about a different analogy as corrupt as
banks maybe as much as banks might be
taking advantage of poor people for
example you can't fight that by robbing
a bank robbing a bank remains a crime
either way if the investigation was
truly worthless if there was no possible
criminality by Trump that he was worried
about you don't fight back and fire
people and tamper with witnesses and
prevent depositions and interviews you
say I look forward to being vindicated
and we'll cooperate in any way that I
can this is again not the way an
innocent person behaves yeah I know I
know this is like a tweet and not an
action but in a way it's a more
clear-cut example of obstruction of
justice yeah because when Trump fired
Comey or dismissed Flynn there was an
argument to be made that well he is the
president he has the right to fire these
people sure but saying that you're going
to fight back that's as clear as it gets
I think this is not an action but it is
an explanation as to the motives of
other actions that he has taken and
that's why it's very important and
that's the one saving grace here right
in terms of the semantic debate around
whether fighting back against a federal
investigation is in principle
obstruction of justice which is a
Trump's characterization is that he is
fighting back but that that's not a
crime what matters is what the law says
about Trump's actions right Trump's
characterization of obstructing or
fighting back doesn't matter the
question is what is the justice system
believe about the actions Trump has
taken to fight back when your fight
interferes with investigations or goes
beyond the law in terms of contact with
witnesses for example it doesn't matter
what you call it what matters is whether
what you did is against the law today's
episode of the program is made possible
in part by Coins schedule which is a
listing site for cryptocurrency icos
that's been around since 2016 it was
actually one of the first websites to
show helpful listing information about
icos you can look i ciose up by name
industry the end date the start date and
coin schedule gives each IC o---- a
score using an algorithm based on dozens
of parameters that help determine how
trustworthy an IC o---- is for example
whether or not the identities of the IC
o---- team have been verified whether
the IC o---- has a white paper and other
factors like those they don't try to
make predictions about the long-term
success or failure of an IC o---- often
that's actually impossible to do what
coin schedule does is provide users with
a combined score of how much operational
risk there is four different icos so
that you can know where to be extra
careful when you see a low rating if
you're watching on YouTube I've put a
link to the coins schedule website at
the top of the video description nothing
in coin schedule should be considered
personalized investment advice icos are
risky people should do their own
research and make their own decisions